good evening I'm Tom Sharpe president of
the Academy of Motion Pictures
authorizing it is my pleasure true
pleasure to welcome you to the third
annual governor's awards yes it's only
the third year we've done this as a
special evening but we've been giving
out these awards for 84 years and our
three honorees tonight a part of a truly
extraordinary tradition one of the
things I love about these evenings is
just looking around to see who we are
we're not just movie stars the big-name
directors were also sound wizards and
costume artists and documentarians and
executives if you allow me a moment of
personal privilege as your president
there are two people who are not here
tonight two of our own two people who
left us too early in life to dear dear
friends who are an important part of our
Academy and our history Laura Ziskin and
Gil case
for us they were family each produced
Oscar broadcast Laura did it twice 2002
and 2007 and she did it beautifully Gil
did it 14 times setting a new standard
for bravery but they did so much more as
you know Gil was a founder and artistic
director of the geffen playhouse and
enriched the cultural life of Los
Angeles tremendously Laura Laura helped
raise hundreds of millions of dollars
for cancer research despite her own
illness she was relentless in her quest
to find not only a cure for breast
cancer but a cure for all cancer those
of us who suffer from cancer Oh Laura so
much thank you my dear friend thank
they were brilliant and warm and
irreplaceable and we will miss them
deeply please please stand with your
glass of moet champagne and join me in
the very first toast of the evening to
two incredible people to Laura and Gil
may your souls rest in peace
you